[موسيقى]
في حي السيده زينب يقع واحد من اجمل
البيوت الاثريه بيت السناري الذي بني على
الطراز المملوكي هذا البيت هو احد البيوت
الفاخره التي بنيت للصفوه في اوائل القرن
الثالث عشر
هذا البيت كان ملكا لاحد المماليك ابراهيم
كتخود السناري وتمت مصادرته من قبل
الفرنسيين عندما جاء الحمل الفرنسيه على
مصر في اواخر القرن الثامن عشر ليكون مقرا
لاعضاء لجنه العلوم والثقافه التي جاءت
معنا بوليوم بونابرت
[موسيقى]
هذا المنزل بني على طراز العماره
الاسلاميه وفي تسعينات القرن الماضي تم
ترميم المنزل واصبح مركزا ثقافيا تابعا
لمكتبه الاسكندريه
[موسيقى]
رسول الله
خلال شهر رمضان يستضيف بيت السناري ليالي
المقامات الروحيه سلسله حفلات غنائيه لها
طابع ديني تراثي بيدينا رمز انه التاريخ
لا يجب ان هو يهمل هو انه هذه الابنيه
التاريخيه زي ما هو البيت ده تبع للاثار
واحنا واخدينه بننتفع به تنتفع به المكتبه
لاقامه هذه الاحتفاليات
[موسيقى]
هذه الليالي في شهر رمضان لنعملها في شهر
رمضان انها بتؤكد على
المعاني الانسانيه الرائعه تؤكد على
المحبه والتسامح والسلام والقيم الروحيه
ايضا بشكل في نوع من الرقي وفن السماع شهر
كريم تفتح المناطق الاثريه ابوابها
لفعاليات ثقافيه دينيه
[تصفيق]
الذي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات